[Musique]
et
et oui le look années 80 revient en
force sur les vidéos youtube et il ya
deux types de personnes qui l'utilisent
à ceux qui payent des plugins hyper cher
et puis avoue bande de petits veinards
qu'elle et apprendre à le faire
gratuitement sur final cut
et ça vient tous des amis aujourd'hui je
vous explique comment donner un look
vintage années 80 à vos vidéos et ça
fait tout drôle parce que moi je suis né
dans les années 80 et donc je suis
vintage c'est je suis pas comment le
prendre en comme je suis vachement sympa
comme verbe si vous avez la flemme de
reproduire l'effet que je vais vous
montrer bavouzet même préparé un petit
précède tout près mais ça je vous
explique comment le récupérer à la fin
de la vidéo
allez c'est parti on s'y colle alors
vous pouvez travailler directement sur
vos rush mais je vous conseille
d'utiliser notre geste met en colère
mais si tu ne sais pas ce que c'est bien
je t'invite à aller cliquer sur la vidéo
qui s'affiche ici première chose à faire
on va d'abord dégradé un petit peu
l'image pour ça on va rajouter les faits
ajouté du bruit
[Musique]
alors on a différentes possibilités
ici on va pouvoir régler le type de
parasites mais nous on va rester sur
parasites tv puisque c'est ce qu'on veut
c'est l'effet qu'on recherche
on peut régler un petit peu ici la
quantité le bruit qu'on va vouloir avoir
va pas pousser trop non plus mais on va
en mettre quand même suffisamment et
l'opacité n'a pas touché
ensuite on va rajouter un petit peu
d'aberrations chromatiques mais rien de
très compliqué pour ça on va utiliser
l'effet prisme qu'on va déplacer sur la
john cryer et ensuite on va pouvoir
régler la quantité de d'aberrations
alors là c'est pareil on va y aller un
petit peu doucement parce que sinon ça
va être moche
il n'y a plus rien et là ben voilà c'est
parfait je vais rester comme ça voilà
ensuite on va passer sur la base de
fignolage c'est à dire ajouter des
petits détails des petites subtilités
mais c'est pas obligatoire si vous
voulez avoir un effet rien 80 c'est
vraiment pour aller un petit peu plus
loin pour pousser le détail pour pousser
le vice jusqu où l'on fait
pour ça on va pouvoir rajouter les faits
grains de film hop
ici on va regarder realistic comme ça ça
modifie pas la couleur ici voilà on est
bien on peut encore une fois toujours
pour fignoler rajouter un tout petit peu
de vignetage vraiment un tout petit peu
là il y en a beaucoup trop ça a sombré
beaucoup trop à l'image et enfin alors
le summum du fignolage s'est rajouté un
petit effet fish eye
alors bien sûr qu'on va réduire au
maximum parce que sinon ça serait
dégueulasse mais un tout petit peu pour
bombay l'image dans le centre pour des
formes et pour finir la wii dans les
années 80 on avait des bons vieux écrans
cathodiques donc on va aller rogner un
petit peu sur les côtés pour obtenir un
format qui s'approche du 4/3 donc pour
encadrer on va tout simplement ici moi
je préfère le faire
moi je préfère le faire ici à leur
gauche on l'a recadré de de centre et
droite on va recadrer de 200 aussi et
c'est pas plus compliqué que ça vous
fait dire qui en a qui paye pour ça
quand même
et pour gagner encore plus de temps si
vous voulez pas vous emmerdez à
reproduire ici tous les effets que j'ai
appliqué mais je vous ai fait un petit
précède que vous aurez juste à
télécharger et comme ça on fait glisser
les faits sur le rush sur la john cryer
et hop années 80 style et même que si tu
sais pas comment installer un preset je
t'ai fait un petit tuto très rapide dans
la description de toujours qui
t'explique comment les installer
et voilà les amis c'est tout pour
aujourd'hui si cette vidéo vous a plu
n'hésitez pas à mettre un gros coup de
testeurs sur le pouce en l'air qui se
situe juste en dessous de cette vidéo
pensez à vous abonner si ce n'est pas
déjà fait partager sur vos réseaux
sociaux
moi je vous dis à très bientôt pour une
vidéo et surtout surtout surtout rester
curieux
[Musique]
oh
oui
[Musique]
m